plus pvm a dévoilé sa toute première
politique sur les interpellations
policières dont elle prévoit désormais
pour toute interpellation que ça devrait
être basée sur des faits des faits
qu'ils devront être vérifiées qui
devront être justifiées les agents vont
devoir remplir des fiches informatives
de leurs interventions donc on peu
documenté tout ça j'en parle avec que
sylvain caron c'est le directeur du
service de police de la ville de
montréal bonsoir monsieur carreaux merci
d'être ici
expliquez-nous ce qui change c'est quoi
exactement cette directive basse une
politique évidemment suite au rapport
des chercheurs de la top 2019 faisait
état de lacunes au niveau des pratiques
policières lors alors le sperme s'est
engagé des landes en 2019 de faire une
rédaction d'une politique nous première
pour venir encadrer la pratique
policière que les interpellations
policières
alors aujourd'hui on a présenté cette
politique officielle a aujourd'hui dans
le courant de la journée
c'est la première politique existe au
québec la première spvm également au
québec à qui permet le policier de
comprendre évidemment puis de paramétrer
une interpellation qui est une pratique
policière qui existe depuis toujours
alors c'est un changement important on
ne me dit et vous précisément sur les
gestes qui sont posées par nos policiers
au quotidien par les patrouilles alors
de différentes interpellations qui
s'effectue ce territoire une
interpellation ce n'est pas une
arrestation c'est quoi exactement une
interpellation une interaction une
interaction sociale avec le citoyen dans
un but d'aller chercher son identité
suite un appel d'un citoyen ou sur une
relation des douleurs besoin quelconque
est exprimé ou une situation un fait
absorbable cissé qui viennent changer un
petit peu on a on a indiqué dans la
politique que le policier au volet qui
documente les faits observés dans une
situation bien précises puis donné le
contexte dans lequel il fait 7 cette
interpellation là ça peut être une
personne qui déambulent sur un trottoir
c'est un appel de citoyens puis le
policier se déplace pour aller voir ce
qui se passe donc en parler de races et
systémique en légende et non ce sont des
gens grands tours qui en ont été
victimes vous savez ils disent écoutez
on se fait on se fait interpeller
on est obligé de décliner notre identité
la raison pour laquelle on est de 6 pour
le simple motif que soit on est noir une
personne restait une personne
un amérindien par exemple est-ce que ce
que vous nous annoncez aujourd'hui ça va
changer cette pratique là les rapports
de la politique aujourd'hui vient
répondre ou une partie du rapport que
les chercheurs ont produit en octobre
2009 en nous disant qu'ils avaient des
billets systémique dans nos
interpellations
alors pour éviter les disparités dans
les interpellations cette politique love
bien évidemment clarifier la façon
d'intervenir
indépendamment de la personne racisées
ou non on y voit aussi des faits
observables
alors nous pas si travers partie de
févier précis que l'on veut c'est fait
l'eau qui n'était pas documenté opéra
l'ap qui les hisseront avec le système
d'informatique sur modifier la façon de
compléter la fiche permettront aux
policiers de bien documenter les faits
et le contexte dans lequel ils
effectuent leur interpellation
bon alors finalement ce que vous voulez
ses archives et sa documenté à une fiche
c'est pas un rapport c'est que poste
comme s'il y avait une amende ou une
arrestation
mais la fiche qu'elle garantit à nos
concitoyens que le policier va la
remplir c'est une bonne question
évidemment il reste toujours la question
de répéter le chiffre noir on se
préoccupe pas encore de cet aspect là
parce que il faut que l'interpellation
soit dans le cadre de la mission de
sécurité publique notre policier alors
bouddha du service alors si
l'interpellation qui a eu le passif et
dépôts vraiment une personne qui n'est
qu'une personne qui veut le faire là les
fils ne paraît vraiment raison d'être
lorsqu'on veut créer a précisé son
citoyen de se retrouver dans nos banques
de données mais en même temps avec nos
policiers assurent quand même la
sécurité d'un territoire
alors on est encore un questionnement
par rapport comment vont évoluer
alors on est ouvert à faire des
changements pas modifier la politique au
moment venu on a donné un nouveau mandat
aux chercheurs pour aller justement
contextualiser les les interpellations
de six comtés de noter les nouvelles
qu'on ferait à partir du moment que la
politique sera en vigueur après avoir
fait la l'information la session de
sensibilisation de nos policiers clés
précis se l'approprient il y aura encore
un amendement dont fait partie le
chercheur d'aller voir d'une nouvelle
fiche d'interpellation je comprends que
c'est un processus en continu la poule
ans et aujourd'hui
je comprends aussi l'importance pour
vous ça prend un bon motif parce qu'en
fait ce qu'on veut se débarrasser du
racisme systémique cloud et bien que le
policier peut avoir une personne précise
et dans un parc vin je vais aller
chercher de l'information vous voulez
plus ce genre de choses là
ceci dit il ya encore des choses qu'on
apprend aujourd'hui la personne quand
elle est interpellé
est ce qu'elle est obligée décliner son
identité est ce qu'elle est obligée de
répondre à toutes les questions du
policier ou est ce qu'elle peut
simplement dire écoutez vous avez aucun
motif valable je réponds pas tout à fait
les droits des personnes lesbiennes
peuvent changer le droit des personnes
la politique d'aujourd'hui alors à 20
les jambes un peu plus l'obligation de
s'identifier s'ils n'ont pas de motif si
la police n'a pas de motif d'arrestation
j'ai juste des faits observables par
rapport à une situation la personne des
citoyens écologistes identifier alors
c'est toujours la même chose pour la
politique la politique vient donner aux
policiers un paramètre de l'intervention
pour l'ensemble des policiers de service
peu importe construit sur l'île de
montréal ce qui est un peu intriguant je
voudrais dans le point presse que vous
avez donnée aujourd'hui si vous êtes si
elles se poursuivent encore les
interpellations sur son des raisons qui
sont lille assez bien systémique assez
bien raciste
vous êtes on va on voit comment
accompagner le policier ça donnait
l'impression qui aurait pas de sanction
en fait j'aimerais vous précisez votre
idée là dessus
ok il ya des systèmes qui existent
présentement la déontologie policière
qui est une instance complètement
dépendant du service le règlement de la
discipline il ya des possibilités pour
les citoyens déjà de porter plainte dans
les différents postes de quartier ou par
téléphone
alors ça ça change pas ce qu'on veut
évidemment si on parle de bié système et
parfois c'est des billets qui sont est
conscient à ce qu'on soit avec c'est ce
qu'on déploie comme politique et les
coachs parce qu'on veut mettre placer
des gens on va équiper
on va avoir peut-être une dizaine de
personnes qui vont être sur le terrain
souterrain vie précis des policières
départ qui vont accompagner nos
policiers pour s'approprier cette
politique et en même temps vérifiez
aussi nos policiers ont des billets
alors ce qu'on veut évidemment dans le
mécanisme de prise en charge
si une personne un gestionnaire des
textes qu'on un policier pour avoir une
policière pour avoir des billets on veut
d accompagner pour que les gens
réalistes finalement signer bien
non pas nécessairement des gens qui sont
racistes alors je pense que c'est
important que les coaches de laquelle on
déploie avec sept points deux cyclos
plus travailler de près avec les
policiers finalement ce que vous voulez
c'est que vos hommes aux femmes face une
crise de conscience prise de conscience
puis on veut vraiment changer et
s'adapter
évidemment autant 2020 alors morial
change le service est en train de
changer [ __ ] on est en ébullition
alors on dit que c'est parce que
maintenant les gens sont très très
conscients de ces enjeux là surtout
depuis l'histoire de georges klein aux
états unis là et les manifestations
qu'on a vu ici
mais j'aimerais qu'on dise les mots
clairs mme boulet est ce que vous
trouvez qui en a duré 6 systémique on
sait votre wii à du racisme ou scène au
quai conti khedira systémique c'est pas
que les policiers sont racistes c'est le
rapport nous dit que l'art est
systémique se traduit par des biais
système et les disparités des
interpellations alors c'est un premier
geste aujourd'hui important de faire une
politique et on veut continuer à faire
d'autres gestes
on a évidemment ça sera pas difficile de
changer la culture parce que si on
regarde ce qu'a dit par exemple le
président de la fraternité des policiers
monsieur francoeur lui dit il y en a pas
de risque systémique
il ya peut-être à l'occasion des
individus mais ya pas de récit ce
système et à tel point que vous avez
plusieurs de vos policiers qui font
partie de ce qu'on dit précisé qu'ils
écoutaient sa faute de mon sens il faut
quand même qu'on reconnaît ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes à
l'intérieur de notre culture policière
on est une organisation publique qui
existe depuis 100 sociale sont des six
ans plus de cent sont des 16 ans alors
clairement il ya des dans notre système
il ya des choses à changer pour
évidemment que ça durera systémique
système nos politiques ne les ya des
choses à changer bois je reconnais que
des choses à changer qu'on va changer
graduellement au fur et à mesure
d'ailleurs on se faire accompagner par
un sociologue pour justement avoir un
regard externe pour poser les bons
gestes ou non m'importe est ce qu'on
comprend donc c'est un premier pas mais
vous allez nous annoncer autre chose
dans le courant de l'année
mais pour le moment cette année c'est ça
on a donné un nouveau mandat aux
chercheurs on va laisser travailler les
chercher qui nous accompagnent puis au
fur et à mesure que des changements
importants ont voulu comme cru bon
dernière chose
retour sur cette jeune fille de 15 ans
qui a été arrêté dimanche sont
surprenantes dans notre dame de
un concours ans d'histoire sa mère a
fait une sortie sa mère est d'origine
philippine à lui c'est la seule un
groupe de jeunes qui a été arrêté et
c'est la seule qui était assise et selon
ses dires elle aimerait vous rencontrer
elle aimerait en discuter avec vous
est-ce que vous allez accepter
l'invitation
toute personne qui désire rencontrer une
personne issue du spvm
on a déjà nos prix prévu dans une
mécanique de travail de prévu alors les
gens et quelques expédients kg prendre
contact avec madame puis ou faire mieux
que les discussions ont rendu au bureau
où il ira mais je vais pas commenter
l'événement comme tel qui est arrivé et
j'en commande pour tous tel contexte
dans lequel nous policiers intervient ça
va se retrouver devant un trio bientôt
par contre on est ouvert outre heures au
dialogue alors il ya des gens dans la
dalle de services qui vont prendre
contact avec madame il y aura des suites
à cette demande de monsieur caron merci
beaucoup pour cette entrevue
merci beaucoup en soirée au revoir